مستشفى 57 3 57 اكبر مستشفى لعلاج السرطان
الاطفال في العالم مهدد بازمه الماليه
[موسيقى]
2007 ويعالج نحو ثلاثه الاف طفل سنويا
مجانا وبتكلفه تنتصر اليوم الى 950 مليون
جنيه مصري كل عام نسبه الشفاء بين الاطفال
تقدر ونحو 71 بالمئه
[موسيقى]
مستشفى 57 3 57 يعتمدوا بشكل كامل على
التبرعات وفي السنوات الاخيره وبسبب بعض
الازمات الاقتصاديه منها ازمه فايروس
كورونا ارتفاع سعر الدولار والازمه
الاقتصاديه العالميه تقلص حجم التبرعات ما
ادى الى اغلاق فرع المستشفى في طنطا كما
تم تاجيل الخطط المستقبليه بزياده عدد
الاسره لاستيعاب عدد اكثر من الاطفال
عمر يوسف نشر فيديو عن هذه المشكله مناشدا
للناس العوده للتبرع حتى يستمر المستشفى
في تقديم خدماته
[موسيقى]
مش قادر خليهم 500 مش قادر خليهم 100
صدقوني الجنيه بيفرق معهم
[موسيقى]